*pewdiepie on drugs*
TAAAAAAAAAAAAA
Fa
Phra
PHRA (slowmotion)
Nice sledghe hammer
PRAAAAAAAAAAAAAA (rowr)
Give up pewds! (no)
*Roars* Sh-shut the f*ck up! (you bald?)
Felix, just stop, just stay. (RAWR)
This game is not for you. JUST GIVE UP!
RAWR (pewds stap)
Why you naked?
This game is  easy(o rly)OH WOULD YOU LOOK AT DAT o look at (sex noices) new world?
Look how easy it is
look how easy this game is
Look at this i'm gonna, do some crazy shit *hoe*
That wasn't as crazy as i imagined in my head, what about this then, what about this fam
What the fuck, okay, this game is so easy
Look at that
Wait how the heck am i gonna get up there
You know what, I bet this is super simple
I bet you family, this is easier
Oh look at that, oh no!
Almost had it first try, baby, this game is all about
overcoming your fears
Look, at that look, at that so easy, my god this game
Look, at that easy(bullshit)
easy, brother
Yes grab the fucking hand there you go easy, oh my, god, oh no, what is down there?
*realizes the impending hell awaiting below*
What is down there no no i can't i can't go do all that let me-
*christian channel music*
Oh, my, god what is down there?
I'm just gonna check. Just so i know what we have to deal with
Okay, we're safe apparently the game developer decided not to be an asshole all of a sudden i don't know, why
But i think, we got to land on that hook over there
Look at that though
Can't believe I struggled
in this easy game
If you complain that this game is hard
uhh you need to complain at your mama
for not-
look at that- look how easy that was
you need to complain at yo mama
Because she clearly has been cuddling you your whole life. i bet you're still
Sucking on them nips
I know how to make these now huh
HUHAAHHAUUH (what is this sound tho)
OH
Easy, easy easy i told you
this game is easy(how many times are you gonna say that?)
"oh you shud give uup"
shuttheffuckup
Disgusting
i bet you you didn't do this on the first try baby
FIRST TRY
YEAHH
EURAGEJLHA
P P P P PO PO *shooting sounds*
I'm shooting man milk out of my nipples
you got a problem with that? talk to my lawyer
Wait what the heck is this?
what the, heck are you do curry(?unknown word sorrry)
No how am i gonna get across that, that's crazy, that's, way too high, oh i see,
oh i see
I think i know how- what i gotta do look at this alright look at this look at this fam
ohh look at that.. HUPP
NO no no no
OHO WHoaAhohO
You got a little scared there didn't ya
"oh noo he almost fel-"
sshutt uup i never fall
I never fall i have never fallen in my life
BPHRA
MMM
easy
EASYY (WARNING HEADPHONE USERS)
AHAHHAHAAH (is he oki doki)
"oh poods you are so grate at this gaem"
I know
I KNOW
wait for real tho how am i gonna do this
it's- it's a wall there where am i supposed to go
Down here? ow
Hey, look, there's a bunch of other pots here that's cool
Did you ever know that you're a part
BBPHRA
Where am i going
this is very confusing
i don't know, where i'm going i know, nobody's knowing i check out this or five whichever(??) where the wind is blowing
I guess we're going back boys
oh
It's a meatball everybody, i know how to climb meatballs
oh god i'm sliding. Oh there it is i see it i see it too long, oh no, oh no, oh god, oh, oh?
I peed a little bit
OHHH
Fucking snow they just had to add snow in the game
butter and a booper yeah butter and a booper ahh butter in a booper AHH
ah ah ah butter in a boopah butter in a boopah
badabadabadababaBA (jumpscare ahead)
BAH
SHADABADBADBADABARDABA
badabdabda
bada
Stupid, it's my mousepad okay, my, mouse pad is too small i have the smallest fucking mouse pad
Can someone please invest in a mouse pad for me
Whoop. i can't like, look how tiny it is. look how tiny it is
i can't go up and down on this bitch. i did not study
Industrial engineering and management
For three fucking years to fail at this easy ass game okay
This, is the easiest game ever made ever made ever made this is the easiest
Game ever made ever made, ever made, ever made
That's right that's so easy i can do it blindfolded, i can do it blindfolded. you want me to do it blindfolded huh
huh huh huh you want me to do it you, want me to do it you, want me to do it huh
you want me to do it a blindfolded Huh, you're are you crazy, oh you come now, crazy i'm sexy
Suck a dick suck old all of the dicks god damnit fucking piece of shit this game is garbage
This is a garbage ass game. ain't scared of anything
fearless how can you be so handsome
fearless
Attractive perfect i know what you're thinking love is blind
Hello mr. Meatball, we meet again
Very good mr. Meatball. now, where is that slimy, oh? God he, slides he slides on this meatball
You're, not supposed, to slide i'm just gonna investigate where is it okay?
Just investigating right now
Of course this is so easy. Look at that!
SSO SMOOTH
SO SMAATH x3
another one
Guardo, me guarda, me, mama mia pizzeria
gorgonzola in my asshole, oh
How, about that?
Gotta gorgonzola got a gorgonzola for everybody
Everyone gets one little gorgonzola hurry up everybody hurry up
come on
come on everyone gets a little bit of gorgonzola
If you hurry my little child, hurry for the gorgonzola. i know how much you love the gorgonzola
gorgonzola
I want some gorgonzolaa
gorgonzolaa
gorgonzola gorgonzola gorgonzola gorgonzola
GORGONZOLA GORGONZOLA GORGONZOLA GORGONZOLA GORGONZOLA
HO HO HO ho ho ho
I looked it up and Gorgonzola is an Italian cheese?? well also a city but yeah
gagagaggargagargargargargagar (help him)
i panicked it's fine it's, fine, it's fine, it's fine. oh, my, god i cry so hard
fuck
FAN I HELVETES JÄVLA FITTA (DAMN IN HELL FUCKING PUSSY sort of)
Piece of shit fucking-
Ohh
Mamma mia the meatball
HOOOAAAAAHH
Noo jesus, oh my, god is that land?
Is this how Christopher columbus felt?
he was filled with anger
That's why
BHRA
OOH OHH HAA
Don't say hej innan du krossar (läcken?) FELIXX (don't say hey before you cross (the lake probably idek)
OHHHHH
*starts singing, some vEry nIce singing*
what do I gotta do now? get on that bucket?
Huh, i've seen, streamers try and do this because they ride the snake, do not ride the snake, this has to be easy right
I'm not gon- it's not even a snake
*burps*
Go away snake i am not interested
oh god oh, god okay, let's not mess around here
oh god it dangles
guys it dangles
ohWow that was so hard people struggle at this shit? honestly go cry to your mama
I AM this game. okay, you're dangling a bit much for my flavor stop it
stop the dangling
stop it
Look at that, perfect
Perfect harmony and balance look at that
Couldn't be better than that
What what how, the hell am i gonna do that
next episode you will find out now
Excuse me thank you leave a like leave a like for meatballs and excuse me cuz
I gotta go back at yuo
Get this on trending